hello and welcome to this video playing
Thomas telesur my reading it's below 23
yeah not having a good couple of days
recently conceding really many points
okay so check the best way of getting
the beggars just to play better not to
ask yourself what what happened down
let's see job this is a this is an
opening line that is considered to be
quite good for white but it is not easy
to play because of the bad development
um yes he takes d5 think black goes be
60 is mmm ah I think you actually can
play before even though it looks very
shaky white has some no pieces developed
I don't ask me how this continued how
this continues I have no idea but I
think before is correct yeah I somehow
thought that this is right but I
couldn't really figure out what happens
are the queen bee three here night on a
voice is misplaced and Bishop d7 looks
wrong somehow don't know what black does
here yeah this one maybe but I can take
on b5 I mean I'm aware of my development
but still I mean this is a temple and on
that night so I think nitey to ed 5v5
should be should be the right
continuation taking on your sixes just
just too much so I think I have to
develop thanks IAM ed five then e five
looks writer yeah
97 I expect night age five there's
probably just 24
well it seems ok I still keep my porn
because I mean I one I have 11 point
earlier and I can know it's interesting
hmm ok I go Bishop d3 I think he
probably no no one that's still good
Bishop a for the screen to be one and
now he has to go back to eight now okay
Bishop d7 I did not see beforehand but
it doesn't really um doesn't really help
him that much I think yeah I can take h7
but I need I need to support the e5 pawn
anyway so if he has to lose a temple now
for g6 or age 6 i'm side with it k Nia
g3 is not so great for my development
maybe maybe 19 and castles next and i
also have night f5 on f6 i think i have
e cigs and 36 rupee 8 f 5
and okay if I castle this community
forum
I had slightly awkward edit so it's very
nice to have this have this pawn on f5
but not so not so not that easy to play
him we should be too wavy
hmm slightly nervous slide the an
ammonia sis position if I'm not if
nothing bad happens in the next two to
three moves then why just wins with f5
andy sixx but yeah it's not it's not
that ammonius g4 for example could be a
move ok probably Queenie for then
yeah that does not seem to be so
dangerous and okay if he gives me some
time what am i doing there should be
three maybe four castles really like to
casa let's move 22
as the point is also dangerous I'm not
not sure about this position at all yeah
I can yeah I can't cash for him but 24
check and it looks kind of strange I
don't see anything but I feel that
something's off here
quindi twinbee to last night c4 yeah
yeah I thought look at four is good the
Queen doesn't have squares
yeah it looks decisive should be
decisive I don't know it was a very
tough position to play objective do you
think white was a lot better but it was
hmm as I said very murky black forfeits
on time yeah okay let's let's go back
somehow it doesn't want to accept my
entry here want to look back come on
okay yeah what I remember is that this
is not particularly great for black this
line here with with this and this is
supposed to be not good but well it's a
long time it's a long time since I
looked at it okay tix should be right b6
before my DA form and queen bee three so
okay let's have a look here what does
the engine give how interesting the
engine wants to play Bishop to d7 the
idea being the demotic here this is
actually a move s9 txt for as possible
now get that's super dangerous so I
think I probably have to have to play
that a little bit a little bit less
materialistic something like this now
Bishop here or something like that yeah
I know that might be good for white but
it's it's really really really really
tough to play okay this I don't believe
really we had the computer even wants to
play Bishop c6 but I couldn't bring
myself to snatch even more material I
wanted to get get something developed we
should be 7 s interesting definitely
think this is probably probably best and
info also looks good j now the check am
okay here i can go g3 maybe g3 is better
I don't know I wanted to have a more
normal I wanted to castle simply put but
I never really got to that anyway so
maybe I should do this g3 Queen here and
King f2s given by the engine with good
with almost a win for wine I also have
this idea it's pretty good huh it's
probably better than my move ok I have
six and now maybe you so I don't know
maybe it's good but it was difficult to
play a computer wants to castle and says
I'm winning because of this
don't quite get it black goes back here
okay I'll take so the engine gives this
is winning yeah maybe I'm I mean this is
a good very good development in all of a
sudden and many active pieces while his
pieces here are not doing much yeah okay
if the engine gives plus 2.5 it is versa
it's very likely correct in this open
position but this wasn't clear it really
wasn't yeah the engine is going back 20
something equal ish yeah I had the
feeling that this was was not going so
well castles and now this this and this
is the the blonde all right hmm yeah
then that you care for was for spinning
this is this is the move that the
computer gifts with a good position
black I Amin equal it says equal but
this is pretty good considering how bad
it was yeah okay do I have to take
difficult not to and there's also this
idea so I cannot just develop I'm 53 m
ok I have to take it check King edge 193
yeah that's not fun
the computer wants to make it roll here
with this I say yeah this is no small
that made I can take with the night I
wonder send no way to continue to play a
like Bishop d2 or something like that I
then I have to anyway whoops huh would
be one something like that the night a
form now I've like a super active of
call yeah so he blundered in a
completely okay position here and I
should have castles yeah that's much
stronger than e6e 6nt f5 looks very
tempting because if you yeah you get to
calm down his initiative you're winning
with those poems but he gets especially
I didn't really recognize that he gets
if I for the night and very dangerous
okay well thanks for watching